welcome back everybody Avengers endgame
is out now and we're gonna keep talking
about spoilers spoilers Rafic s--
spoiler graphics in this video we're
gonna be talking about unanswered
questions we have from Avengers endgame
and there's quite a few joining me today
Hector Navarro lost backhoes develop a
nation and Scott mance one of my fav
film critics we're doing the high-fiving
ran unanswered questions let's get into
it my number one leaving the theater was
what happened to Gamora from the past
that comes to the president and then
does she get dusted what's going on
there because here's a question maybe
you can answer this from your comic book
knowledge mmm-hmm
when Tony does the snap sure does it
have like a moral compass like how does
he know to just just the bat that's my
question that's it that's a great
question there's there's been some great
videos on the internet where some people
have used science to theorize it the
original snap that Thanos even hid
because it's such a crazy thing to think
about but it is a very easy to
understand idea half of all life in the
universe will be you know snuffed out in
a nice dusty way some people have said
like okay well the stones what they do
is they assign every life and either a
zero or one and all the cereals get done
like they've like tried to like like get
married
yeah like exactly to use those like
logical rules to make it make sense I
know this is comic book logic and it
doesn't make sense but I would imagine
that everything that Tony Stark went
through including the friending some
guardians of the galaxy and infinity war
and then learning about what has
happened and in reflecting on it for
five years she's probably he probably
has some awareness of Gamora the other
daughter of Thanos he spent time with
nebula right so he probably knows about
her was he thinking about her when he
snapped it was he trying to save her I
don't think so I think that what he what
he set out to do was I want Thanos and
his army to disappear right now I think
that's what he did and I think that that
means that the universe decided Gamora
is probably not a part of that because
she we all know that she kind of isn't
and then in that final battle she did
she has the moment she rebelled so the
end of the film showed star-lord looking
for searching for Gamora and his ship
with the as guardian of the galaxy Thor
conceivably setting up Guardian to the
galaxy vol 3 but this is a Gamora from
2014 who never met
star-lord who never had those adventures
in the two movies that we saw
so that I think that she is around
because we didn't see her specifically
yes and I looked I looked for the song I
thought it was like where she in the
background it's like no she's not there
that's my question about like why I did
like a when Thanos snapped his fingers
why I knew half the population half the
adventurers disappear I'm an Iron Man
snapped his fingers all the judge guys I
see focused yeah it's all it's like just
like calm empathic you know the way you
know the Infinity stones work like Danny
or you know a Tony Stark just said I
want to just get rid of all the bad guys
and boom yeah yeah I think um another
question I had was and you guys can
chime in whatever questions you have but
huh what was up with Loki taking the
tesseract I think we kind of talked
about this in the last video but I mean
we essentially think he's like went to
his Disney Plus show yes for sure
basically yeah because that creates like
an like the way that Tilda Swinton
explains it creates like an alternate
branch yes and the way that marco bike
actor named the way that the Hulk you
know tried to explain it was saying that
just by their nature of going back in
time they were creating an alternate
universe
you know we had cat versus cat fight we
had Iron Man or ant-man creating like a
little mini heart attack for Iron Man
that did not happen in 2012 so this is
an alternate universe the difference
here is that when the stones were taken
out of there the avengers promised to
bring them back so conceivably they
brought them back the difference is is
again that universe is a universe where
Loki got away and we don't know what
happens after that so right now Loki has
a tesseract it's 2012 it really is like
that's what it is it really is like Back
to the Future
yes he goes back in time am i going back
in time you've now created you've set
the path for your own for a future that
you want to be like the future that you
know right but it's not going to be
perfect because back to the future you
know Marty went back to 1985
you know George b5 was like a stud but
that's because he interfered with his
own yeah and back to the future rules
which I love that this movie called out
as being bull was that bad is it Marty
went back to his own past and just
started changing things in it kind of
like laid over itself yeah where's the
Avengers are like as soon as they go
back boom new branch new bran so they're
affecting things in that branch their
past still happened intact as they
remember it but now we're gonna see what
happens with the Disney Plus show this
leads me into my next question though
then how did cap go back great question
I have a theory okay one of tweet let me
try to get it out the structures will
know
sure people right now watching the
mess-up peggy's timeline and then live
his life and then still show up on the
same bench like shouldn't he be in
another one of two options the first
option the first option which i think is
the option but it might take a little
bit of explaining maybe they'll show it
to us someday
is that Steve Rogers doesn't fact go
back to an alternate timeline gets
married and has a life with Peggy Carter
and then when he's an old man still
using his knowledge and the coordinates
of where he originally left maybe he had
his own little technology bracelet we
didn't see it his little time-travel
thing he uses that that information to
pop over to our current regular timeline
why because he left it knowing there's
no Captain America here and I'm gonna
give my shield to Sam maybe in his Peggy
Carter timeline he still ended up
meeting Sam but he was an old man and
he's like here's the shield maybe he was
acting as Captain America in the 50s 60s
70s maybe he ran for president maybe he
made the world better we don't know what
happened but that's an option and I'm
hoping that with Steve Rogers being as
cool of a dude as he was that when he
goes back to the 50s he really was like
I could I can I can make this place
better like I'm not gonna put up with
intolerance like I'm really gonna I'm
gonna go on marches I'm gonna help
people that would be cool but I think
that one option is he just popped over
to our dimension hand it off the shield
and maybe popped back okay the second
option is which is kind of messed up too
Wow the second option is Steve Rogers
goes back in time with me linear and the
stones and conceivably puts everything
back where it goes Mjolnir in 2013 right
in Asgard so that everything still
happens Thor the dark world go back and
re-watch it puts the stones back where
they belong and makes it specifically so
that he goes for like back further
enough that it is our timeline and when
he goes to that that timeline that we
are already familiar with from Captain
America the First Avenger the Winter
Soldier the agent Carter TV show all we
know is that at some point Peggy Carter
gets married she has a husband she
mentions that in that video
yep that he saw at the Smithsonian in
Winter Soldier right you know she says
my husband was saved by Captain America
in World War two he was always changing
my life even after he was gone and then
all we know about that Peggy is it in
2014
she's older she's losing some of her
memory and young hot Steve visits her
his best gal and she Burt you know she's
a good it's been so long like she kind
of loses it in that moment and it was so
so tragic
what if Steve went back in time married
Peggy and then he changed his name
he never had a picture of himself taken
and Peggy was in on it for decades and
it was in fact our timeline and when
Peggy said my husband she was referring
to Steve and she had to pretend as
though she lost Steven in 1970 when
she's one of the directors of shields
just to pretend that she doesn't have a
smokin hot husband at home and
everything happened exactly the way it
happened up until 2014 where Peggy was
being visited by young Steve older Steve
is maybe still around but he can't be
there because that's part of the
agreement is that he needed to make sure
everything was gonna be the way it was
gonna be
maybe Peggy was even faking it when
Steve shows up and she's like Steve
you're back it's been so long because
she has to keep up the the thing of like
I never married Steve Rogers so all of
that could have happened it could have
been a secret and that that meant that
that old man Steve after Peggy even died
in 2016 right at the beginning of
Captain America Civil War Steve was
still around for a couple years holding
on to that shield seeing all the events
of everything Avengers and Iron Man and
everything and just waiting waiting
waiting until five years from from 2018
which is 2023 he goes to that Park sits
on that bench waits for them to do their
time-travel stuff then Sam walks up any
handsome the shield so one of those two
options next question
obviously there won't be a new Tony
Stark but we'll do you guys think there
will be a new Iron Man TJ pepper was a
one-and-done do you think Morgan Sark
will come up and do uh well first of all
we've seen different Iron Men mm-hmm are
people in the common I hope you know
there was a there was there was a
storyline back in the 80s when Tony
Stark was battling alcoholism and he was
replaced so the sky's the limit but
Captain America and with Iron Man yeah I
think those characters will continue but
they get to think about it think about
how great this is for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that you get to
continue with the brand awareness and I
I don't mean that in a and a negative
it's a positive it's a positive thing
you have to continue on with an Iron Man
film series but have a whole different
actor or actress playing Iron Man and
have a whole new set of adventures you
can have a whole new set of a trilogy of
standalone films so we get into light
you face six it's gonna be who do you
think who do you think I'll be the first
person we see first character to be like
it the lead of an Iron Man centric movie
that is do you think it'll be the kid
from Iron Man the funeral Harley b3 is
underrated
I mean I love what they did with the
Mandarin we still need to see the real
Mandarin and so that's right Ironman
should face off against Miyagi is a
freaking G it's great it's great
questions our case eating it - whoo yeah
whoo D what to see what's that what our
options we've got rody Yeah right
war machine because he's war machine
right we've seen him in somebody new
somebody that we've seen that we've seen
in the MCU but not but not a mystery
character so it's there's not gonna be
pepper not gonna be rody is it gonna be
Tony's daughter Morgan maybe maybe could
it be a new character we haven't seen
yet RiRi Williams again possible Morgan
you got a do it way down the line right
so but if you if you go with with your
suggestion and you get to start from
scratch exactly still stand those other
characters will eventually still meet up
with Ari we reread like happy Hogan can
show up Pepper Potts you know everybody
could jump be like we do she's like a
minor man you need an Iron Man the world
scene Steve Rogers Captain America you
know like that was a not very subtle
passing of the torch that's another
thing I was wondering is like will we
ever call Sam Wilson cap or do you think
well I keep wanting to call him fountain
so I think so I think that when he and I
just at this moment and like that is
that well smell good for her for a long
time Rogers was cat but now you know
moving forward as as Sam Wilson earns
the see she wrecked correct he will be
cat which to steam right to say that's
gonna be but that's gonna be a moment
yes when someone says call it cat got it
yeah
cat it's it's a moment of the Sam Wilson
as a characters comic-book history he
was Captain America for many buyers and
he was called cap and he did earn it and
all that still happened the cool thing
is is when he was Captain America he got
to keep his wings so he was like a
falcon with a shield like it it was like
a red white and blue motif like it was
really really cool so in the same way
that I hope that someday we'll get
she-hulk I hope we get Jennifer Walters
and different versions of Hulk maybe Red
Hulk maybe maybe a bomb but especially
hat what's that obviously the black cat
black cat from spider-man spectacular
spider oh okay okay black cat that might
be
I think usually Peter mytopcollege years
Jenny drew spied him through through the
black hat we shall Hardy back at late
eighties yeah that was the way to go all
right I was hoping Monica Rambeau who
was like what in 25 days or something
you know yeah I was hoping she would pop
up at some point mm-hmm mm-hmm
here's my star check reference I'm
hoping that when we do see a grown up
Monica yeah and she is either photon or
pulsar or her own Captain Marvel version
of the character like the comic books
did we get great Star Trek actress
Sonique Oh Martin green could player I
think that you would she would be amazed
she would be amazed she would be amazing
having a hello come on Kevin I know
you're all I know you're a Trekkie
fighting crime and great phenomenal
actor and I think that she's been like
fan cast a lot even Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers was a character we've only
recently been introduced to right
they've retro actively gone back and
said she's been around since 1995 is
when she was first active as Captain
Marvel and she could have either been
visiting earth or at least up until 2018
during the events of infinity war she
came back to earth saw that Fury was
missing but then she's kind of been
bouncing back and forth which is just so
exciting for story possibilities and if
and when we get a Captain Marvel - not
only will hopefully we see a grown-up
Monica but we also have to introduce a
character of Miss Marvel Kamala Khan a
very popular superhero character a young
girl who grows up idolizing Captain mark
like we need to set that we need to
plant those seats yeah of having that
little girl growing up in a world of
sure with all these superheroes but
specifically she's looking up to Carole
and then when she gets powers and
becomes Miss Marvel it's awesome another
timeline question I have yeah it has to
do with Peter Parker yes maybe it'll be
explained and far from home but
everybody who got snapped right like
they come back and they're the exact
same age correct they did not age five
years so when he goes back to school or
like half his classmates like five years
older and often voyage and that's a
great question - because like when Peter
Parker went back to school med Leeds was
still in the same grade maybe so that
maybe there Ned was snapped also yeah so
snaps are they're essentially stuck in
frozen in time or here's another option
and this is why I think it was really
really smart to announce spider-man far
from home as being really the end of
phase 3 when
was first announced people were like
look that doesn't make it should be the
nfinity saga ending with endgame that
doesn't make any sense
but then you watch endgame and there's
all these questions about like the
logistics of the snap so it's gonna be
spider-man that kind of explains like
the sort of regular person like reaction
to everything yeah I think far from home
is actually going to yes and I think it
will explain how people are coping and
what they're dealing with and let's say
for example if Peter Parker was snaps
he's gone for five years from 2018 until
2023 then we rejoin him in his
classmates in 2023 but let's say Ned was
also not snapped but again we saw a
little bit of how the world was
shattered by half of everybody
disappearing right just just everything
like like government's kind of weren't
working to full capacity I imagine maybe
schools weren't either possible I don't
like the apocalyptic I was like they
haven't cleaned this up you know who's
gonna do everyone's surviving bright
Pepper Potts is reading a book on
composting like it was dire so maybe if
Ned even though he wasn't snapped but
he's still around maybe by July go back
to school and just kind of keep
progressing in grades maybe he's kind of
like got some version of the GED and
they're kind of waiting around they're
like well maybe our super heroes will
undo this and that just kept going and I
don't we see the iron spider outfit in
any of the footage for spider-man far
because he cuz that was a special going
off of the planet suit that Tony Stark
gave him when he goes back to his
neighborhood he's wearing his regular
suit but even in one of the trailers for
far from home he knows he's going on a
little vacay to Europe he leaves a suit
behind it is until he shows up
in Europe Nick Fury is there I think
that's when he gets a cool black and red
stealthy I've said gotcha I think wasn't
there a shower she liked it Aunt May
like leaves like a note that's like you
forgot this at home or something like
that oh with his suit maybe it's cool
but anyway I hope that and I'm looking
forward to this movie answering at least
some of those questions without really
trying to like break the logic of the
story like obviously there's just see a
spider-man story that's what's most
important but the fans kind of do want
some of those questions answer and I
think we might get some of them um
another question I have I think it's
pretty obvious but for is with the
Guardians so there you go coordinates
vol yeah guardians of the galaxy yeah
it's right off
should be the title it should and
there's been even a comic name that I I
was worried when I watched that moment
that maybe the filmmakers decided to do
that last second because the issue with
James Gunn it happened that was mine I
was like is this their way to get tyka
on board to like basically go and direct
Guardians volume three which is a
franchise it is so near and dear to
James Gunn's heart that maybe Marvel
Studios was like well what if we just
put Hemsworth on the ship with tyka then
wanna maybe talk about but I'm really
hoping that when James Gunn was fired
that Kevin Feige kind of you know pulled
out all the stops and was like we're
just gonna not even put this film into
production even though we have the
script like it's so important to James
let's wait until this stuff maybe kind
of blows over let's reassess let's
rethink it and hopefully the news of
James Gunn going and directing another
superhero movie with their competing
studio helps everybody to kind of
reflect and figure out that oh it sure
that'll do it so in any case I'm just
glad that James Gunn is coming back and
it seems like everybody the cast
everybody they're super stoked about it
but I'm also really glad that Hemsworth
continues to play this character that
last scene with them trying to figure
out like who's boss who's the boss
essentially I that was like my favorite
one of my favorite scenes maybe I was at
the end of a three hour movie yeah we're
all like let's keep going yeah it was so
good yeah um this one we has been
explained but it's been coming up a lot
a lot of people have asked me who's the
kid at Tony's Harley keiner there's
madam and Iron Man 3 which is underrated
I agree with Scott man 2 yeah it's it's
you know they'll think of the different
it's it's different here's the things
Iron Man 3 took chances mm-hmm and that
was Shane black like he liked that the
twist in that movie would he do with the
Mandarin play by Oscar winner Sir Ben
Kingsley it's complicated right it's
complicated hey it's complicated yes
it's complicated that was so unexpected
and I understand why fans were like as
much as I love spider-man if they did
something like that but the Green Goblin
urban pissed that's true why Spidey
doesn't usually face off a bunch of with
a bunch of racist caricatures from the
60s so I think it was a kind of a smart
you know like before right now yeah for
the sake of a movie yes is something
different the way they show that the
Iron Man's who wasn't working I mean the
movie was more about Tony Stark than it
was about I am
till the very end yeah III and Haley was
a great addition to that film it's not
usual it's not typical that I think I
think mine's being a little bit of Peter
Parker yes totally we can start to see
Tony Stark sort of frame of mind with
that in the way that he is wait it's a
type of Harley it's kind of the same way
that he is with his daughter yeah when
he tells heart when Harley cycle my dad
left you goes that's too bad so sad and
like drives away he's kind of he's
ribbing with the kid he does the same
thing with his daughter go to sleep I'm
gonna set your toys and she smiles and
you know leans over like that's the
beginning of that and Harley keener it's
not often that kid actors and big movie
franchise franchises like this that are
sort of inserted are like cool and funny
and beloved but this is a movie that I
have never at once heard somebody
complain I didn't like the kid and I
ruined the kid would yeah exactly
exactly which is a common thing
especially from like comic book fans so
yeah Harley keiner and I feel like this
funeral scene should just make everybody
go back and rewatch every single movie
in the MCU that's that's what should
happen 100% do um do you guys have any
wrapping it up do you guys have any
unanswered questions when Captain
America took the soulstone back did he
meet Red Skull again for being a Nazi
I'm so sorry Captain Steve son of Edith
you are you beat me up in World War two
and I have learned my lesson I'm sorry
for being a racist Nazi I don't know
what happened great question I had
questions about like when Tony gets the
stones from fan OHS like how the hell
did he do that yeah but they were like
you see remember in MN in the wasp when
Scott Lang learned close-up magic he
taught that to Tony Stark but like like
early on the movie they're like like
really like gently putting into the
glove like they're all about to be blown
just like to be like magnets
he was like Matt watch look if I go like
this I got your ring that was a great
moment when McDonnells goes like this
and he turns it over
I am inevitable and then Starks as I
know okay guys well we could talk about
this movie for 10 more out what's like
no we're gonna wrap it up okay thank you
guys so much for being here Hector where
can we see your work you can follow me
on the internet at Hector is funny and
check me out on El Rey nation every
Thursday night at 10:30 check your local
listings on the El Rey Network you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
movi mance and you can catch my all my
reviews on my website at movi man scott
and i'm a - carlson and you can find me
right here this is my house
[Music]